marant picked up by curry again curry
with five fouls shot clock at three
marant gets inside a little push shot is
good 33 for john morant and a
three-point grizzly lead
finishes this play uses the upper body
strength to shield off steph curry and
create
more space take advantage i'm the
franchise guy
make a play and shoot at the last second
four to shoot morant makes his move
spins in the paint turns puts it up
puts it in john morant knocks it down
it's a five-point game with 4.5
remaining
35 points for moran and the grizzlies on
the verge of making the playoffs
spectacular plays from the former rookie
of the year in just his second year in
the nba
this is just great time management
and poise the crossover the spin
and again that nice little floater that
every great guard has to have
15 points in the fourth quarter in
overtime
35 for the game
and they are 4.5 seconds away
from making into the playoffs they have
stunned this crowd here at the chase
center
many of the fans now heading for the
exit